un crimen que sacude a Francia el
asesinato de una niña de 12 años ha
desatado el debate sobre la política
migratoria del país la principal
sospechosa es una argelina con historial
de desórdenes psiquiátricos que había
sobrepasado el período de permanencia
previsto en su visa de estudiante y
tenía orden de deportación el escabroso
crimen asaltado a la palestra política
de nuevo Lo digo la sospechosa de este
acto de barbarie no debería estar en
nuestro territorio Y eso se extendió por
tres años eso es demasiado muchos
crímenes son cometidos por inmigrantes
clandestinos que no hemos sido capaces y
hemos tenido la voluntad de deportar
[Música]
la respuesta inicial del gobierno ha
tratado de desplazar el foco del terreno
político
primero déjenos respetar el dolor de la
familia y dejemos que la policía la
justicia hagan su trabajo
jugar a la política mezquina usar la
muerte de una niña de 12 años como
trampolines vergonzosos señor como soy
Si tú
no añada el indigno oficio de la
demagogia la más absoluta atrocidad
pero mientras crece la indignación
Popular y luego de que el presidente
macroón se reuniera con los padres en la
niña asesinada al gobierno francés ha
tenido que hacer un ejercicio de
autocrítica obviamente debemos hacerlo
mejor y estamos trabajando duro como
dijo el ministro del interior esta
mañana para asegurarnos de que las
órdenes de deportación tengan
seguimiento de acuerdo con un reporte
del senado
9,3% de las más de 143 mil órdenes de
deportación emitidas el año pasado se
cumplieron ahora el gobierno francés
lucha por volver a poner el foco en los
verdaderos desafíos de la inmigración